the to Tom medal winner at the 2016 Rio
Olympics and I do believe Chris Brockman
I just got a glimpse of why she's
referred to as the human emoji for
outgoing facial expression okay because
Laurie Hernandez I do believe you just
made this shocked look when you heard
that kid Harrington the king of the
north himself from Game of Thrones is
going to be on the show later in third
hour yeah he's beautiful
you like yourself some Jon Snow so what
do you say is it okay it's okay
you know if you can build a house from
trees and the woods that I drew nothing
then hey if you can go from the Lord
Commander to dead - alive - king of the
north and that's it you're done it's a
done deal should you like Game of
Thrones um I've seen a few episodes but
I brought the catch up on it okay so I'm
behind you can't my gosh did I just give
up some spoilers done I technically know
you didn't because my brother already
spoiled it for me is that so yeah okay
well thanks for coming on the show good
to see you here thank you for having me
this is so exciting I'm so excited to
have you here you are up for an espy
tomorrow night Best Breakthrough athlete
we'll talk about that shortly Europe for
Kids Choice Award that's coming up later
on this week as well so there's a lot
coming on but I wanted to ask you what
is it like being a 16 year old from old
bridge new jersey representing our
country on a stage and real what in the
world was that like for you
between your temples to deal with it was
definitely nerve-racking I think we'll
all the girls on my team two of them had
gone to a previous Olympics and then the
other two I've been to World
Championships and then I went to
Nationals a year before and so it's a
really big difference in competition so
I was definitely really nervous but
because the girls had so much experience
they also helped me kind of find my way
throughout the pop like what what did
they what did they help you with well
they did warn me that it was going to be
a really loud competition and I was like
yeah you know it's fine I've been too
loud meets but the arena was actually
dome-shaped so the cheers echoed off the
walls and okay it was loud that's a good
heads up when did you first start I mean
when when did when did this all begin
for you so I started in 2005 I was five
years old and one day I was just at home
watching TV a gymnast came up and I
realized people good luck and so I kind
of pointed
scream at the screen and I looked at my
mom and said you know I'm gonna be just
like her and she said okay she put me in
and she put you in what I mean well how
does some because I'm sure there's so
many people that see you and have been
inspired by you and have little girls
I've got a one that's about to turn four
at home she crushes her somersaults
right now Holly I got to tell you her
thing that's the first order of business
okay yeah she's great at it my dad would
get mad because I would do flips on the
bed and he was worried I would hurt
myself
I know I'm the same way too right now
okay what so how do i how does somebody
go from from that to to somewhere where
you're sitting right now I guess you
kind of start off doing classes just the
basic classes I mean there are also
classes called like Mommy and Me where
you go with your parents or do so it
rolls and whatnot but um eventually I
mean when you feel or when coaches feel
that your kids like really is able to
progress them they start putting you in
levels like there are there's pre-team
and then there's like level 3 level 4
and then you have to go all the way up
and that's just um there's a lot of
steps to go up but you just have to be
patient with yourself of course I'm here
with Laurie Hernandez two-time medal
winner at the 2016 Rio Olympics and by
the way congrats on your dancing with
the star championship a year ago right
here on the Rich Eisen show in person so
uh how long days though I mean did you
have to put in it was were years I'd
imagine correct yeah it was a long time
I mean I did gymnastics for 11 years
until the Olympics but it was typically
I mean especially right before the
Olympics it was about six days a week it
was like give or take six hours a day
but we had breaks in between so right
wasn't bad but uh it was definitely it's
definitely tough okay
and now now so what what else do you
want to do with your life what do you
what do you what are you looking forward
to doing I imagine College yeah I mean
I'm definitely looking forward to
college in the future I'm looking
forward to hopefully acting that would
be okay something that I'm definitely
interested like what sort of acting you
talking about I mean I'm still exploring
I just actually did a show called stuff
in the middle for Disney I played myself
but it was so far acting so it was it
was a lot of fun and I had a lot of fun
really meeting everybody on the set and
being able to kind of memorize lines and
just to do it over and
it was funny so comedic acting is what
you're just something that you're into
okay all right I'll do it
what about the 2020 Olympics I'm
definitely looking forward to that as
well and you're ready you're going to do
that cross your fingers
I've been taking a little break since
last year's Olympics but I'll probably
ease my way back into gymnastics again
at the end of the summer okay so you'll
get back into this and you'll get going
what what colleges have been knocking on
your door or you knocking on what doors
of colleges I mean well I mean I'm
really looking well I'm looking at like
like NYU and UCLA and colleges along
those lines but I saw I haven't decided
yet
can I can I kind of make a suggestion to
these yeah there's a Michigan Wolverines
helmet right here I mean you could do
gymnastics at the University of Michigan
I actually I'm not allowed to do
gymnastics in college is that so yeah
did I just break a recruit did I just
did I is in Sierra Leone line one is
name tampering I have no official
capacity with the University of Michigan
other than the fact that I try to talk
up the greatest institution of higher
learning ever known to man I'll look
into it
Hey look into egg still go to college
it's not like a thinker no no I
understand that but just ok cold in
Michigan Laurie but yes Oh bridge New
Jersey it's not like that's you know
yeah and you leave the cold to get to
the warm what are you thinking not wrong
okay but you're a New Jersey I your your
your musica okay so what are your sports
teams would you grow up uh yankees and
giants definitely
okay I grew up in my house my dad
especially my dad and my brother really
look forward to sports but actually my
best friend is a mess and a Jets fan so
I'm you know it's a little hard and
House when they're playing against it
you know I know that I I'm not sort of
rare New Yorker we're Yankees Jets on
that rare breed I'm Alec I'm Jay I know
so one of them one of the people you are
up against for Best Breakthrough
athletes
tomorrow night for the ESPYs is last
night's Home Run Derby champion Erin
judge Erin judge he's incredible I got
to go to a Yankee game a few weeks ago
and me and my parents like we got to
walk on the field and everything and
it's so funny that I am and nominee
with him that's insane I mean my my dad
really loves thank you so much I think
my dad might be voting for so if you if
you lose to err a judge
I don't let's take how many seconds
would your dad be disappointed for for
now I'm getting up I'm doing I was doing
dad I love you full 60 seconds right
when it all comes down no he's
definitely voting for me but it's just
kinda shows goes to show that my family
is a really big Yankee fan we do love
Aaron judge and we think Houston awesome
play did you meet him did you know we're
not yet okay hopefully soon that's
across well I'm wondering he might you
know know any SPN they're probably
getting ready to fire up some sort of
private jet to take him from Miami to
the all-star game right out here to Los
Angeles and if you do you know I did we
did we did take a look at this of the
height differential between you and the
rest of your compatriots in this you are
you're five feet flat uh yeah I like to
tell everyone I'm 5-1 but that's a lie
okay so all right and then you know
Aaron judge is six foot seven but Jonas
at edicom both of the Milwaukee Bucks
six foot 11 six 11 yeah I could I could
sit on my own shoulders as you know not
be as awesome I'm kind of you know I'd
like you to win but I'm rooting for that
tie because I'd love I'd love to just
see that shot is that wrong for me to
say no not at all I mean I think it
would be really cool to just see me like
hanging on his arm or something what
this whole experience has been like for
you Dancing with the Stars the
championship of that as well as you know
obviously your Olympic experience
getting two awards that you're up for
this week and people know you want me to
the street I mean how do you keep your
head screwed on straight quite frankly
oh boy I mean it's definitely been an
absolute whirlwind it's been something
that I'm not used to at all I mean a
year ago nobody really knew who I was
and now it's kind of like a no or a
baseball cap whenever I go anywhere but
um it's it's really a blessing honestly
it's a I have a lot of opportunities
that I get to look forward to and I get
to kind of share with my family but my
family is really that set that keeps me
grounded and keeps my feet on again well
and in that respect you know I shouldn't
ask you to drop a name because you know
strike me - name dropper but do it
anyway who have you met through this
whole experience that you were so fired
up that you got I will be on same day
also pretty cool was that like was that
circumstance like um she's tall why
everybody's appalled everybody call
against me but uh right yeah she's tall
um I actually I meant CC Sabathia when I
went to the Yankee games whose hand is
like the size of my face it's really
crazy um I got to meet Noah syndergaard
actually he is also a tall being told me
all Avego
like name is Thor cuz you throw out a
first pitch for the Mets right I did how
did that go for you um I'll stick to
gymnastics okay that's all yes baseball
is something that I should work on
that's okay well we'll give that to
Aaron judge over let him know so I threw
out a first pitch for the Dodgers and I
would have I would have fooled
left-handed hitter with my my off-speed
pitch but I would have hit the
right-handed hitter Wow actually plunked
if there was a right-handed person and
the batter's box I'd have hit that I
don't even think that my ball went to
the catcher is that right I think it
went somewhere over there okay I'll tell
you what though everything everything
seems to be turning out just fine so
congrats in advance of everything that's
to come ain't uh the University of
Machine is a great place to go should
you so choose and I for the television
audience that's going to stick around
would you mind teaching me the most
basic gymnastics maneuver I'll let you
know of yeah absolutely discussed this
before the show Chris Brockman and I and
Chris you suggested cartwheel yeah
freebase that is not basic um I'll call
you come on cartwheels pretty basic yeah
what do you mean pretty big it cuz that
involved that involves balance strength
and the ability to not kill oneself
there is a landing that must be stuck
isn't there a maneuver that does not
require a landing you I mean if you
don't stick it's in this mountain every
problem need I remind you you fell off a
skateboard once with Tony Hawk I know
that well I got without hurting myself
by the way I know I saw
jet landing why don't we try Hansen
that's not a bad I think I think that's
heading that way harder than a cartwheel
yeah I mean does not require some sort
of upper-body I mean I dealerships a lot
zooming we have a solid core that we're
well know I think we could do why don't
I teach you at the gymnastics landing on
a proper landing I will do that how are
you thank you can use the whole thing is
I'm going to be in your capable hands
when we come back television audience it
the radio audience if I'm not here
you'll know something very terribly
wrong happened well thank you because
I've got I've got Laurie Hernandez here
Clay Matthews still to come and then in
the third hour the king of the north
from Game of Thrones Kit Harington will
be here on the Rich Eisen show don't you
dare move we'll be back with more in a
moment
all right Laurie you're about to teach
me what are you about to teach me that
it's the most basic gymnastics maneuver
you think I can handle as a 48 year old
man with children I'm going to teach you
how to properly land a skill
okay and I will finish okay just to
finish how do I do that what are we
ready we're dices so first for the most
part every skill lands like this went on
two feet bent legs or put your arms kind
of running you know okay yeah yep like
that feet together that's a deduction
there you go Wow Wow like you're it's
like you're from East Germany over there
yeah no I'm a Jersey girl okay and then
you want to finish like this nice
fingers yeah we go yep okay oh why put
that hand what I Harris okay like like
that um sure what I would say jump off
cuz I got it I'm gonna jump off this
land on the Rich Eisen show nimble all
right I will watch my heritage okay rock
me to sleep so knees feet together plant
and then why be together
feel you know keep your knees bent when
you Lynne okay absorb into the ground
okay here we go
I believe in you you're a natural you
don't get a music for this Mike
please play the music here we go
yes tens across the board incredible
really right
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience isn't it amazing
you can download an app with your
thumbprint you should download our app
with your thumbprint